welcome to our session on designing for
observability on Google Cloud Charles
and I will be your host for today we are
both product managers in cloud logging
so before we talk about how to design
for observability let's take just a
moment to talk about what observability
is and why we care the concept of
observability actually comes from
control theory where it's a really
important concept because the system can
only be controlled if it's observable
meaning that you can understand the
internal States from the external
outputs it's a concept we use every day
in our thermostats car dashboards and
more for cloud computing observability
ties directly to reliability and helps
us answer questions like what's this
code actually doing is my system healthy
where's my system having problems
what changed how can I improve my
performance and even reduce my spend so
the three things you'll need for
observability our logs metrics and
traces since observability can require a
lot of data
you'll also need a system to store and
organize all this data fortunately we've
got that part covered in Google Cloud by
using the same planet-scale
platform that we use internally at
Google to power cloud logging and
monitoring I frequently get asked by
customers if they can send a few hundred
terabytes of logs per day we measure
volumes and quadrillions of metrics and
exabytes of logs and now Charles will
tell us how to get started let's talk to
an example to highlight the
observability needs of the organization
of the product and how it helps you meet
that needs
imagine that you're in charge of the
DevOps or SRE team at the company and
you just started using google cloud this
is a new technology for your
organization and you professionally
though your leatherwork worked with
other cloud service providers your job
is to develop the observability plans
for the infrastructure and applications
while every organization is unique there
may be common cases across web
what specific requirements may be a bit
different you can tailor your usage to
meet those needs first there's a
development use case in our example
company different teams run a diverse
set of applications monitoring the
applications in infrastructure is
handled by the DevOps or SME to
troubleshooting is an important use case
and use defined in fixed application
infrastructure issues the last use case
is compliance many companies and
organizations have compliance
requirements now let's take a look at
our example Google cloud infrastructure
our cloud environment supports different
teams in different environments dev
staging and prod environments with
multiple project all centralized within
a single TCP organization there are also
custom developed application servicing
end-users and your custom and standard
business level applications for internal
organizational users the environment
includes real-time analytics and run iam
pub/sub in big part it's a fairly
standard enterprise or set up on Google
5 to design and build observability for
Google Cloud you need a few key PD items
first you need to collect the logs and
metrics metrics and logs allow me to
build dashboards and alerting for your
monitoring and troubleshooting use cases
if you can instrument your applications
you can add support for tracing which
allows you to see the performance and
optimize your application or cross
services once you collect the logs and
the metrics and traces you then need a
tool that will help you interpret those
signals which are - does all the use
cases the developer monitoring
troubleshooting and compliance this is
exactly what the Google Cloud operations
suite provides to you and now there's an
exciting new feature in cloud logging in
the cloud operation suite that we'd like
to share with you thanks Charles
so one of our key goals for
observability is being able to ask
questions and find answers and to do
that you often need the data to be
stored together it's one of the reasons
that our architecture uniting cloud
monitoring logging and trace into the
cloud operation suite
is so powerful well since we launched
the cloud login router last fall to give
transparency and control over the logs
you want to keep for observability and
also develop an open ecosystem for our
partners we've gotten great feedback
from our users and partners we've heard
that you love being able to use logs
things to send data to different
destinations and exclusions to fine tune
that volume of data but we've also heard
that you'd like that same ability to
send logs to cloud logging in a
different project so that you can
centralize your logs within cloud
logging we're really excited to announce
today a number of new log management
features that can help improve your
observability starting with expanded
functionality for the logs router you
can now use the full power of the logs
router to send logs from projects a and
B to project C including setting up a
sync at the folder or org level so that
all the child projects are inherited
this is really great for security
applications we do this by introducing
log buckets as a first-class storage
solution using log buckets you can
centralize or subdivide your logs based
on your needs from the name log buckets
may look like cloud storage buckets but
they're built on the same logging tech
stack that we've been using to deliver
your logs in real time including
advanced indexing and optimizations for
timestamps log buckets also allow you to
take advantage of advanced management
capabilities including customer
retention which we've just made
generally available and also newly
launched regionalization to log buckets
one of my favorite things about log
buckets and they expanded logs router
functionality is that we preserve that
great in context experience and we do
magic behind the scenes to look up where
your logs are stored so you can still
view those logs for your kubernetes
cluster for example right in the gke
consult in project a even if they're
stored centrally in project c finally
for more advanced users we're also
introducing log views to allow you to
subdivide access
within a log bucket so for example
Charles may centralize the logs from all
of these projects but only grant me
access to logs from project a well he
can search across all blocks Charles
over to you to show how to pull all of
this together thank you Mary
our design approach is an iterative one
starting with what's provided and
progressing through the in-depth
configuration a great place to start is
the out-of-the-box logs and metrics
cloud logging collects all of your logs
from route services and even autumn logs
so you know what's going on in the class
time for compute engine you need
additional if you need additional
application long so you can install
agents to collect those logs cloud
monitoring stability collects metrics
while the cloud services by default so
you can build dashboards and learning
when you need additional application or
business level metrics you can use those
custom metrics to monitor those over
time once you're using the
out-of-the-box metrics and logs you may
find that you need specific application
logs or business metrics you can collect
those by using logging and monitoring
agent next you can customize your
experience and you can do that by using
logs based metrics which can translate
your log messages in to metrics then you
can use those metrics to create specific
learning based on your observability
requirements for your environment now
with all of that done the next challenge
is doing so at scale cloud logging and
monitoring both provide ways to
aggregate your logs and metrics with
monitoring workspaces you can route your
projects into a single place and monitor
all of your projects in a centralized
location with logs router log buckets
and log views that Mary mentioned you
can direct all of your logs to a
centralized project or set of projects
now if we go back to our example I'll
demo the step by step the set of best
practices in cloud logging and
monitoring first I'll show you what
logging monitoring provides
out-of-the-box to build observability
you need to start with the collection of
logs and metrics that you need first
I'll show you the logs and metrics that
cloud monitoring and
longing collect out of the box let's
start with cloud monitoring cloud
monitoring automatically collects
infrastructure and service level metrics
out-of-the-box cloud monitoring provides
a summary view of your environment here
you can see the incidents the charts
dashboards and your outcome check first
let's take a look at one of the default
dashboards the VM instances this newly
refreshed dashboard provides a
high-level view of your VM instances
here you can see a detailed view of all
the instances in your environment along
with useful details about each in this
particular DCP environment you'll see
several app servers a gke cluster a
Jenkins VM for CI CD to minecraft
servers and added web development server
now we're running these minecraft
servers because we happen to like
minecraft and it's fun and also it's a
great example of running a Java app on
an instance because minecraft the
version that we're running is actually
running on Java so we think this is a
fun example it's the same type of
experience you have running any
Enterprise Java app on a little server
now the overview tab provides a quick
reference and set of charts in each of
the tabs provides useful information
about your fleet of VMs going back to
the inventory tab you'll notice that
some of the VMs have additional memory
utilization information this is provided
by the monitoring agent which collects
additional information to get a sense of
the additional information is collected
first let's look at the minecraft server
- which doesn't have the monitoring
agent installed notice that there's
information about the instance and
there's a default set of charts that are
available for for the instance now let's
go look at and see what information is
provided for the first instance clicking
on minecraft server one notice that
there now a set of processes that are
listed for the instance as well so these
are all the processes that are running
on the instance and the second thing to
notice is that we have an agent tap here
and the agent provides additional set of
charts and dashboards around memory
utilization disk utilization and
detailed CPU information
what's useful is that you can start
without the agent and then whenever you
need this process level information or
the granular memory information you can
install the agent I'll show you how to
do this later in the demo next I'll show
you the out-of-the-box logging
experience cloud logging automatically
collects your platform logs and a demand
activity audit logs the logs viewer
gives you the ability to search across
your logs and provides a query builder
to help you build your queries this is
the new log viewer experience that we're
using today which includes useful
updates including the logs to Explorer
and the histogram the logs field
Explorer helps you easily refine your
search by picking out top level fields
and values that you can easily add to
your queries when you set select a GCE
instance resource type the query runs
and the logs field Explorer is updated
with the subset of the results the
histogram Graham helps you gain insights
into the frequency of the log entries
over time and jump to the specific logs
for a given time window both the logs
field Explorer and a histogram may be
closed and added back via the page
layout ok so let's take a look at some
logs first we'll look at an audit log
you can easily refine your search to
find the audit logs using log field
Explorer and selecting the audit logs
that are listed here cloud logging
collects audit logs for your services
which include admin activities this
captures that who did what where and
when for your Google cloud services ok
so now that you have the logs through
your admin activities for the VM
instance within the project first we can
look for the first operation in the
audit log and you can match the entries
for the particular request by looking at
the particular operation and then
clicking the show matching entries now
we have all the audit logs for this
particular request next we can say who
made the request by looking at the proto
payload and looking at the
authentication fields so we'll expand
the log and look at the authentication
information
next you can see who made the request by
looking at the proto payload and the
request type here you can see that it is
compute instances stop so in addition to
audit logs logging also captures your
logs from GCP services what is in
collected though by default our logs
written to specific log files or the
syslog to provide this flexibility
though you can install the logging
agents to collect your sis logs and
ingest your application logs you can see
an example of these application logs by
clearing your query filter and leaving
the GC intance c-- instance and then
selecting for example the minecraft logs
we select a log entry and then expand it
and see all the details for the specific
long entry including the metadata as
well as the data generated from the
application itself these logs are
application specific and created by the
job which can be get collected using the
agent next I'll show you how you can
install agents in collect additional log
metrics now let's take a look in our
example we saw that minecraft server one
had a monitoring and logging agents
installed and minecraft server 2 didn't
the agents are built by Google on top of
the open source fluent D and collecti
projects so let's install the agents and
start correct collecting minecraft logs
first we'll start with the monitoring
agent this will just take a minute and
then we'll move on to the logging agent
right now once all the logging agents as
well and you can find the instructions
to install these agents directly on our
documentation once they're done and
we'll check to make sure that the
logging agents have been successfully
installed and started using the service
command there is the stack driver agent
which is the monitoring agent and then
we'll look at the fluent e agent which
is the logging agents both of them
running successfully now for fun will
also customize logs that the fluency
aging collects to specifically collect
the Minecraft logs from the instance and
so to do that we will use a specific
configuration file that I have created
and we will then copy that to the
directory that contains the fluency
configuration and then we will restart
the agent and we'll wait for that to
restart now that it's restarted we'll
take a look at the configuration file
that I use the first thing to notice
here is the path to the log which is the
Minecraft log here and the next thing to
notice is the tag that we get which is
the Minecraft log and this is the entry
that will appear in cloud logging in
this example we're doing something fun
like running a minecraft server however
these are the same requirements that you
have when you're running your own
application or instance with your own
enterprise software to show how logging
is collecting the logs I'll wish you a
command to the Minecraft instance that
will appear in the logs and then I can
find that command in the newly tailed
logs so we'll enter the minecraft server
and I will set the time to zero and once
I do that I can exit the server here now
that we have the process and memory
metrics from the monitoring agent and
assist logs and minecraft logs for the
agent now I'll show you the logs in the
viewer
this time I'll use the query builder to
query from my virtual machine
so here I'll scroll down to find the VM
instance and I'll look for the minecraft
to use server here there it is and then
I'll add that to my query I'll run my
query and then I'll use a log field
Explorer to hone in on the specific
minecraft logs here so there we see if
we scroll down we actually see the time
that we've set to zero so if I expand
this log I can show you the fields very
similar you can see that it's coming
from the minecraft tooth server and it
contains the same text that I just
entered so now you can see that we have
minecraft logs for the minecraft tooth
server and the message that we've
entered and we've collected that using
the logging agent next I'll show you how
you can customize your environment by
creating log base metrics and alerting
now that we've collected all of our logs
let's start making them actionable with
custom metrics and alerting I'll show
you how to create a log base metric
based on the count of the messages from
the application for the example I'll
count the number of times that the
server saves the game this should be a
regular process and log entry there are
no logs from the process over time and
that should trigger a check for them on
the application server start belongs to
err let's add the specific query to
return the logs that we're interested in
next we'll click on the action and then
click create metric this will load the
logs base metric UI we can give the
metric a name and then we can create the
metric now once we've done that we can
actually click on the metric that we
just created here and we can view the
logs we can view the metric in the
metric Explorer to see the details and
we can even create an alert from that
metric so first why don't we look at
another metric that I've created
previously since we just
started correcting this one and we'll
look and the metrics Explorer for this
entry so this is the metric Explorer
this is the interface you use in cloud
monitoring - if you would like to do ad
hoc analysis over over your metrics so
now we can see the regular occurrence of
the metric over time this metric is
useful for dashboards and ad hoc
analysis on top of that we can create an
alert to learn us whenever the specific
condition happened I'll show you how to
do that now we can go back to the login
console and we can look at the logs base
metrics that we have that we created
just a moment ago and then we can create
an alert for the specific metric in this
case I will use the metric that I
created previously create an alert for
metric this will allow me to specify the
conditions here so I will specify the
write aggregator so this helps me
identify the values of the metric that
I'd like to use and we can say is below
- over a given threshold of time in this
case we'll use 6 hours as our time frame
we'll save the alert here this will ask
us to to name the alert and then we have
the option of adding a notification
channel such as an email or any of the
options here whether those be slack or
SMS or webhook or even cloud pub/sub I
want to add a notification channel here
I also have the ability to add
documentation once you do that you've
saved your alert so while we're having
fun with a Minecraft example the same
process applies to monitoring the errors
from your application or the request
volume or the CPU utilization for your
instances next I'll show you how you can
centralize your log
in monitoring now that we have collected
all of our logs and we've built learning
to customize our environment the next
step is essential eyes both logging and
monitoring you'll likely have more than
one project in centralized logging in
monitor makes it easier to find them
makes it easier to satisfy operations
use case and even meet your compliance
requirements log centralization is
provided by the new feature that Mary
mentioned log e buckets the logging
storage sections contains the logging
buckets which is a logical container for
your logs inside your logging project in
this case I'd like to send all of my
logs for the three projects in my
organization to this centralized logging
project to do that I've created a single
bucket called all production logs to
hold my logs for all three projects and
the way that the logs are delivered to
this project
is through a logging sink so now I will
show you the logging sink in the other
project which delivers the logs to this
one here this is the original project I
was showing you
and now we have a logging sink which
essentially takes all of the logs that
specifies that is specified based on
your logging sink and sends them to the
destination that you select in this case
we are sending them to the logs in the
central logging project with all
production laws now if we look at the
sink itself you can see that I have I
have sending it to cloud logging here's
the particular destination in the other
project we have not added any filter so
all logs will be sent and then we have
not opted any any logs out of the filter
as well so this will generate logs in
the in our centralized logging project
so let's go take a look at the logs in
our centralized logging project
so once I have the logs in a centralized
place I can issue queries across all the
logs but first I have to refine the
scope of the query and select the
appropriate login bucket I can do that
by using the refine scope and then
selecting the scope by storage and then
the centralized login bucket and then
clicking apply for example if I select
the kubernetes details I can see all of
the kubernetes resources within the most
demo app including the namespaces and
the pod names when I select the VM
instances I can see all of the logs that
are generated from the instances across
all three of the projects now for the
centralized monitoring I'll go back to
the monitoring summary page and show you
the settings in monitoring there's a
concept of a workspace which can monitor
multiple projects I've added each of
these three projects into the workspace
now by doing so I can aggregate
monitoring across any of the metrics in
the projects I can create dashboards
alerting uptime checks for any of the
metrics captured in any of the projects
and that's it now we've got all of our
logs and all of our monitoring metrics
in the same place now with this
configuration you can search across your
project logs you can aggregate metrics
and your dashboards for all of your
projects I started out by showing you
the out-of-the-box metrics and the logs
collected by cloud monitoring in cloud
logging next I added a date agents to
collect the additional metrics and logs
then I customized for my own
observability requirements by building a
log base metric and associated look
lastly I configure all three projects in
my organization to collect logs into a
single bucket and send that to a single
workspace we built a baseline for
observability which can be extended by
instrumenting your code for distributed
tracing and performance optimization to
learn more about how the cloud ops we
can help you
observability for your systems please
check out other cloud op sessions